I was at SNL with you and with Chris
Farley yeah yeah yeah it was there it
was there when you I was writing there
when you showed up and then Chris Farley
showed up yeah and you guys clicked
right away yeah and one of the things
that's in some some people in show
business are not that people think
they're the wild and crazy person who
they are who they're saying there are on
TV but they're they're not Chris was all
of that and you guys were very funny
together we were just hanging out in the
radio at sent out live it's nice talking
you about yeah because you you saw it
every day and Chris loved you of course
it was that was a real heyday of great
performers and writers like this the
writers were so good to write again yeah
they know all the people that they would
even maybe not know but I know we shared
a little office and then you know
Sandler and Chris Rock had a little one
extra so I had to walk through hours and
Chris was always bored and I was trying
to scribble away and write some crummy
sketches and uh you know when he'd go
even turn around and I go who would say
this is Chris Chris yeah and I go if
this is fat guy in a little coat it's
not funny anymore I don't like it and he
goes no it's not I'm working on new
stuff and I go and I turn honey at my
little Levi jacket on he goes bad guy
little coat don't you quit on it
[Laughter]
every time he would rip it yeah he'd go
oh my god you're gonna rip it he goes
nothing is crying because it ripped all
I did was lean over every he's ripped so
many coats and that's why we put in the
movie because yeah we didn't really have
much to do in there just thing fat kinda
look out here and we're like sure I mean
it just it was stuff and Tommy Boy that
was funny to us that we just hoped was
funny to people and it worked out